carlotta hat gesagt das ist noch nicht
die zeit sei um die beschränkungen
aufzuheben bei uns im studio bildpolitik
chef jan schäfer jan die begründung ist
ganz interessant du siehst darin eine
trendwende ja karl lauterbach hat ich
hab mir das ja ein bisschen mit notiert
gesagt es gibt keine oder weitere
lockerungen sind nicht vertretbar hat er
gesagt und es gibt immer noch 100 bis
150 tote täglich das ist viel zu viel
und eigentlich war bisher die begründung
für corona maßnahmen immer dass vor
einer drohenden überlastung des
gesundheitssystems gewarnt wurde bzw
eigentlich immer versucht wurde mit den
maßnahmen eine drohende überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern davon
war in dem fall jetzt gleich die rede
sondern hier zählt karl lauterbach
plötzlich ab auf die todeszahlen und
natürlich ist klar jeder tote ist ganz
ganz bedauerlich aber wir sind bei wenn
man das im vergleich setzt den
infizierten zahl und den todeszahlen
weit unter dem was wir beispielsweise
zum jahreswechsel 2000 2020 21 erlebt
habe da gab es bis zu 1000 tote am tag
wie gesagt jeder tote ganz ganz
bedauerlich aber die frage ist immer
natürlich eine abwägung schaffe ich es
ein wie ein uhrwerk carlotta war fast
die todeszahl komplett auf null zu
drücken das ist natürlich gar nicht
möglich deswegen ergibt sich hier die
frage diese kehrtwende ist sie
eigentlich gerechtfertigt die es nicht
gerecht werde passt das für dich
eigentlich zusammen dass er jetzt sagt
zu diesem zeitpunkt sind bereite
lockerungen nicht vertretbar aber karl
lauterbach sagt auch vor ostern wir
öffnen weit vor ostern da ist ja nicht
mehr so viel zeitspanne und er sagt wir
sind noch nicht auf dem höhepunkt dieser
mikrowelle man soll das denn alles
passieren eigentlich sind darunter april
ist ostern um es nochmal konkretes genau
ja bis dahin ist noch ein bisschen zeit
gab es sind doch knappe neun wochen also
ich komme mir so ein bisschen vor bei
dem was karl lauterbach ja auch am
sonntagabend bei die richtigen fragen
hierbei bild gesagt hat
man weit vor ostern möchte eröffnen das
ist so ein bisschen wie der hund den man
die wurst immer wieder vor die nase hält
und der ganz ganz schnell läuft und man
zieht die wurst immer weiter weg das ist
eine aussage die steht jetzt ein
bisschen im nirvana das haben wir im
letzten jahr auch schon erlebt wir
erinnern uns als der kanzleramtsminister
von angela merkel helge braun sagte im
winter ja also im frühjahr oder im mai
könne man dann wieder in den biergarten
gehen das war ungefähr ähnlich also weit
weit im voraus aber wir sehen ja dass um
uns herum um deutschland herum in vielen
ländern jetzt gelockert wird jetzt
geöffnet wird jetzt die maßnahmen fallen
und deswegen gibt es eigentlich karl
lauterbach hat andere gründe aber aus
meiner sicht eigentlich keine gründe
mehr nicht zu sagen wir gehen in
deutschland jetzt den weg den auch
andere eu länder gibt andere große thema
jan in dieser pressekonferenz ich halt
mal hier hoch auch der titel der bild
zeitung heute leider putsch gegen
impfpflicht für pfleger heißt es dort
also der bayerische ministerpräsident
will dieses gesetz also diese
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufe nicht
umsetzen obwohl muss man dazu sagen ist
einstimmig im bundesrat also auch mit
der stimme bayerns beschlossen wurde
carter sprach spricht da von einem sehr
gefährlichen signal ja da ist karl
lauterbach erkennbar angefressen gewesen
wir haben auch gesehen das hat
eigentlich die pressekonferenz danach
dominiert genau dieses thema dieser
vorstoß von markus söder und vor allem
auch das was danach kam vom cdu
vorsitzenden friedrich merz auch von dem
gesundheitspolitischen sprecher der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion thilo sorge
der heute bei uns bei bild sagt also man
wolle bundesweit darauf hinwirken dass
die impfpflicht für beispielsweise
pflegepersonal ärzte bundesweit nicht
kommen soll sie soll zum 15 märz kommen
sie soll ausgesetzt werden darauf will
man jetzt dringen und da es karabach
erkennbar angefressen wie du sagst
gefährliches signal sagt er er sagt ist
ein medizinisch nicht zu begründen das
sei falsch und das sei ein falsches
signal
es würde den eindruck vermitteln wir
wären politisch erpressbar das sind
starke worte das sind starke worte karl
lauterbach fürchtet natürlich etwas was
ihm gar nicht schmeckt dass damit auch
die allgemeine impfpflicht ins wanken
gerät natürlich ist es so dass wenn ich
schon die impfpflicht für einen kleinen
einen kleinen bereich von personen
beispielsweise pfleger ärzte nicht mehr
möchte kann ich natürlich auch nicht
sagen jetzt möchte ich aber dass alle
bundesbürger geimpft werden das ist
möglicherweise etwas was markus söder
möchte was auch die union möchte was
karl lauterbach natürlich gar nicht
schmeckt wir wollen ganz kurz noch zu
unserem reporter julius beim schalten
der die pressekonferenz live beobachtet
hat und dort jetzt steht in der
bundespressekonferenz beziehungsweise da
ford julius dein eindruck
ja ja ist gut beschrieben das thema
markus attacke auf die einrichtungs
bezogenen pflicht war auch bei den
fragen hinterher das hauptthema karl
lauterbach war deutlicher angefressen
hat mehrfach gesagt dass dieser
vorschuss von sehr sehr problematisch
ist und das ist ein politischen jargon
schon eine chiffre für
das das ärgert mich gewaltig aber am
ende des tages setzt markus söder oder
spricht markus jedoch nur eine realität
aus die auch schon die behörden gemeldet
haben dennoch die gesundheitsämter
selbst haben schon gesagt wir werden ab
dem 15 dann selbst noch mal eine woche
lange frist setzen müssen weil wir eben
jeden einzelfall prüfen weil wir
menschen die mit attesten anders
erwischen zu lassen können prüfen müssen
wir können das ganze gar nicht umsetzen
und deshalb wird diese debatte um die
einrichtungs bezogen wehrpflicht noch
groß bleiben und natürlich auch den
scheinwerfern auf die allgemeine
impfpflicht die bundesminister karl
lauterbach unbedingt möchte oder dieser
stelle natürlich schwächt
live vor ort von der
bundespressekonferenz vielen dank für
deine eindrücke